I thought I would speak about 20 or 30
minutes I'd like to describe for
lawsuits that are in various stages of
litigation tell you what you're likely
to see coming out of the Supreme Court
and ongoing litigation over the next
couple of three years but at the
suggestion of a few people want to just
start out by telling you how it is I got
in the this sort of sordid business of
kind of undeviating us up by race then
that particular phrase some of you may
recognize from Chief Justice John
Roberts in a case that was decided a few
years ago and that advanced the ball in
ending race-based preferences in K
through 12 he said this is a sordid
business divvying us up by race and
indeed it is a sordid business my
background is not in the law no I am NOT
a lawyer I am NOT a social scientist
although I am a fellow at the American
Enterprise Institute and have been there
now for almost ten years my story is a
little unusual I got into this simply
out of a small miracle that took place
in 1989 and that was my daughter was
accepted to college and um my wife and I
at the time we're living in a garden
variety Houston suburb I was in the
investment business she was in the
insurance business and when our daughter
left home we decided we no longer really
wanted to live in the suburbs we wanted
to live in kind of inner-city Houston i
know david has spent some time in
houston we wanted to move close to the
museum district and your rice university
yet so i think it's a common pattern for
professionals to want to leave the
suburbs after the kids for you can move
closer to this really downtown action
and we did that bought a house
and I went to vote for the first time in
1990 in my new neighborhood and realized
looked at the ballot and realized that
the Republican Party had not fielded a
candidate to run against the incumbent
Democrat no I really wasn't a political
animal but that bothered me that area
everyone should have a choice in
virtually all of their candidate races
so I called the Republican Party of
Houston harris county and i was told
well you know you live in a primarily
minority district and you know
republicans just aren't going to win in
a district like this and that seemed
like a reasonable explanation for
someone who was in the investment
business but the more I thought about it
the more peeved I got and assorted to
cut to the chase two years later I have
won the republican primary to represent
the 18th congressional district of texas
i was now I was now thick in the thick
in electoral politics and faced you know
a very well-known african-american
Democrat incumbent it was an interesting
race because I'm Jewish and I'm
conservative and you know normally that
is not something you find a race like
this is not you know it's not very
typical at least it wasn't back in 1992
needless to say campaign contributions
were not rolling in to support us
so we had to default to what used to be
called simple retail politics or those
of you of a certain age will know before
the internet candidates used to go door
to door knocking on doors and handing
out campaign literature and that's
exactly what my wife and I and all of
our volunteers did I would be on one
side of a garden-variety Houston Street
knocking on doors people would still
answer doors back then by the way and my
wife would be on the other side and I
would go up to a household that I knew
was now in this newly configured 18th
congressional district right after
redistricting and the homeowner would
have a sign for a different
congressional race there and this just
didn't happen once or twice there were
dozens perhaps hundreds of yard signs
promoting candidates that weren't the
candidate of the homeowner and I would
have to explain that you know
congressman bill archer is no longer
your congressman your new congressman is
congressman Craig Washington and I'm the
guy that's running against him and the
reason we had to do this was that block
by block the legislature of the state of
Texas had using what was now in 1992
fairly advanced computer mapping systems
overlap with census data they've
identified almost house-by-house the
race and ethnicity of each voter and
then harvested that voter or that
household are really that census block
into racially homogeneous voting
districts so that if on one sign of kind
of this garden variety street there were
three or four african-american families
or maybe a small apartment complex with
three or four african-american families
that side of the street would go into
one congressional district across the
street if there were two or three
Hispanic families or maybe a similar
apartment
flex with Hispanics that would now go
into a new Hispanic district and the
same thing with you know white families
so multiracial multi-ethnic
neighborhoods were split apart block by
block to create these sprawling bug
splat districts that would go from you
know 80 miles you you've been if you
haven't been to Houston then just
imagine wasps Angeles a little smaller a
little smaller you know a district would
would spread out in one direction for 40
50 miles another direction two or three
miles another direct so that when you
looked at the the silhouette of the
district that I was running to represent
you really couldn't tell if someone
asked you a question you couldn't and
said I live in the the stonington
neighborhood of Central Texas you you
simply couldn't tell that person what
congressional district he or she was
drawn into now this is this is an old
story racial gerrymandering and
gerrymandering in general has been
around but um because of these sort of
technological improvements the state of
Texas along with a lot of other states
north carolina virginia South Carolina
Florida they went through the same
process and created these these these
were shot like districts so you kind of
probably know what happened i didn't
serve in Congress i i i i i washed the
election i ran 10 points ahead of george
herbert walker bush and that was that
was somewhat gratifying in that the the
following election cycle my opponent was
challenged in the Democrat primary and
lost so uh but I this this house by
house disintegration of neighborhoods
that used to be kept together for the
purposes of elective representatives
that bothered me
lots of things bother me yeah and and um
I guess about five or six months after
the election I read about a lawsuit that
had been filed in North Carolina that uh
that had challenged a similar district
that was drawn to connect
african-american neighborhoods and and
and part of the district included just
one highway 1 interstate interstate 85 i
believe the connected the
african-american neighborhoods in
Charlotte with the african-american
neighborhoods I don't know 85 miles away
using a highway just to connect those
two districts so I thought well if they
can file a lawsuit in North Carolina
I'll file a lawsuit in Texas now I had
not what I had never been sued before in
my life I had never sued anyone so here
I was you know in a position of you know
in the investment business needing to
hire a legal team to challenge the state
of Texas redistricting policy excuse me
I reached into my own pocket took out
about eight thousand dollars a month
found a real estate loiter in Monroe
Louisiana who had some experience at
this now the reason I had to go to
Monroe Louisiana is because no lawyer at
any large law firm in the state of Texas
or even small law firm in the state of
Texas thought that I had a chance of
winning or frankly even the folks in
North Carolina had a chance of winning
but i found one guy i pulled together
some friends we recruited sort of this
ragtag team of pro bono lawyers and we
sued the state of texas arguing that the
texas congressional redistricting plan
was an unconstitutional gerrymander
under the Fourteenth Amendment of the
United States we drew a three-judge
panel
we had a one-week trial what we had off
are three or four lawyers at our table
the United States intervene and had like
DOJ lawyer there must have been 50
lawyers on the other side and lo and
behold about five months after the trial
we won ah the three-judge panel in the
state of Texas declared that the Texas
congressional redistricting plan it was
as it was enacted for the 1992 election
was unconstitutional that was a
wonderful victory but then something
unusual happened that no one anticipated
and that was that the state of Texas
appealed to the United States Supreme
Court in order to defend their district
and lo and behold the Supreme Court took
it up so now I have gone from you know
an amateur congressional candidate and
an amateur plaintiff to now trying to
put together a professional team to
argue this case at the Supreme Court
which we did we made arguments I guess I
guess about eight months after the court
took it up and a few months after that
lo and behold we won that case style
Bush versus Vera in a five-to-four
opinion authored by Justice Sandra Day
O'Connor during the course of all of
this my phone started to ring from other
people around the country who were in um
you know similar situations people who
had learned about the case obviously
through the Supreme Court and I asked
one of my expert witnesses to compile a
list for me of the most racially
gerrymandered congressional districts in
the country down to the least racially
gerrymandered districts in the country
and I i took this winning legal team
that now had finally gotten paid from
the from the state of texas that's part
of the part of the beauty of suing under
certain provisions of the Voting Rights
Act and we will we took this show on the
road I I recruited plaintiffs in New
York Virginia South Carolina Louisiana
and Florida and we just started suing
and lo and behold over the course of
about I'd say about four years we struck
down the congressional redistricting
plans of all of those states and and
here's what here's here's what here's
what everyone gained from that although
the states were compelled to redraw
their congressional districts and they
did and i am not going to tell you that
these districts were perfect squares and
circles the these these busted apart
neighborhoods for the most part were put
back together so that multiracial
multi-ethnic neighborhoods pardon me for
the most part now have this commonality
they have a congress person and it
doesn't matter whether you're white
black or hispanic in in these
neighborhoods any longer you can come
together as Americans and as community
members to influence to influence that
that that representative and that
happened you know in all of those states
so I thought that was a that was a great
you know a great beginning to all of
this the day that I won my first lawsuit
at the Supreme Court my business
partners at the investment bank
I was working at identified that day as
the day that my interest in the
investment business collapsed and the
day that I decided that I was going to
become a part time amateur litigator and
that is indeed what is what what what
has happened over the last 20 years my
phone continued to ring from parents
whose children had been denied admission
to a magnet school program in Florida or
Texas or Louisiana oh thank you i needed
that that's good and i started to put
together legal teams that would go out
and represent parents and represent
individuals challenging race-based
policies whether it pertain to
educational issues additional voting
issues contracting issues or employment
issues since that initial case i have
had three cases argued at the Supreme
Court won a case out of Texas in which
we challenged one of the provisions of
the Voting Rights Act called Northwest
Austin Municipal Utility District number
one versus holder better known as num
bud know the blood no was argued at the
Supreme Court in 2008 and we won that
case an opinion offered by Chief Justice
Roberts that gave us a win but it didn't
really give us much of a win it it
alerted Congress that the the provision
of the Voting Rights Act that we
challenged and Manning I think
encapsulated it well Wow in 1965 it was
important for the deep south to be put
under federal supervision because of the
invidious
disenfranchisement of african-americans
there by 2006 these provisions had
morphed into something very different
than what they were used for in 1965 now
they became the very gerrymandering tool
that allowed and encouraged states like
Texas in New York and Virginia to create
these bugs blatt districts so we won the
mud no but we didn't win much during the
course of litigating the mud no I
started reaching out to other
jurisdictions and found Shelby County
Alabama they were a perfect jurisdiction
to sort of put the second chop on the
log we won we won some you know
important legal doctrines with the first
case but I knew it would take a second
one and that case was filed in 2000 and
late 2010 and an opinion in that case
came down in June of 2013 which
basically struck down these provisions
so this provision of the Voting Rights
Act that was used in very mischievous
ways to separate us by race into
different voting districts that that has
now come to an end and my opponents will
never forgive me for that I want to just
sort of briefly talk about college
admissions because this affects all of
us because we all have children and
grandchildren and nieces and nephews in
in 2003 when the Supreme Court allowed
the use of racial classifications in two
cases from the state of Michigan that
may I know Manny was involved in writing
amicus briefs with that those cases were
really were grave disappointments for
those of us who believe that your race
and ethnicity should not be something
that's used to either help you gain
admission to college or harm you in your
admissions prospects the Supreme Court
allowed I think what they described as
the delicate use of race in in
college admissions the day that opinion
came out the University of Texas held a
news conference and announced that they
at the University of Texas who had been
forbidden from using race and ethnicity
in their admissions process was now
going to add race-based affirmative
action on top of what everyone
recognized was a successful race neutral
means of achieving diversity at UT that
successful race neutral means was a
statute passed during the Bush
administration that allowed any student
at any high school in Texas who
graduated in the top 10% of his or her
class to attend any school in the state
and a year or two after that statute
became law the number of racial
minorities at the University of Texas
exceeded the number of racial minorities
that were admitted with affirmative
action so let me make sure you
understand this Texas was precluded from
using race and ethnicity for about seven
or eight years during this period of
time more minorities were in attendance
at UT than before their grades were
better their graduation rates were
higher yet the day the Michigan cases
came down on the university of texas
decided wait a minute we've got the best
of all worlds now we're going to add
race-based affirmative action to this
that was another aha moment to me I knew
that that well I thought was a way for
us to get this issue once again before
the court and I started looking for a
plaintiff to challenge you tease
admissions policies took me about three
years I found two young women who agreed
to sue UT we sued UT in 2008
lo and behold we lost at the district
court we lost at the appellate court
appeal to the Supreme Court and the
Supreme Court took that case and we won
that case in a seven to one opinion
Justice Kagan was recused from that we
even picked up Justice Breyer and brace
yourselves justice Sotomayor agreed with
us we lost Justice Ginsburg now as you
as you can imagine what we won with
Clarence Thomas and and and Sonia
Sotomayor agreeing on a legal point what
was not we didn't win a big buffet we we
won like a little nosh it was like a
little half of a sushi roll but it was
an important sushi roll it was an
important concept and the concept that
the Supreme Court came down with and
that and that round of this litigation
was that in order for a university to
use race and ethnicity in its admissions
policies it must first and they use the
word before before turning to racial
classifications and preferences a
university must make an attempt to find
a race neutral means to achieve the
diversity that they seek ok what is what
does that mean well it means that the
University of Texas had this race
neutral means that was very effective
instead of just striking down you tease
a plan apparently there was some horse
trading among the the justices and
that's why I think we ended up with
seven agreeing to this new higher
standard they remanded the case back to
the Fifth Circuit where we made
additional arguments where we lost again
and now that case once again is heading
back to the Supreme Court I decided that
while we didn't argue in Fisher one nor
will we argue in Fisher to that the time
has come for the Supreme Court to
completely end racial classifications
and preferences I started laying the
groundwork for a new round of litigation
and to that end myself and a legal team
and all of my pals that get these
midnight phone calls from me with crazy
ideas we identified three schools we
identified harvard university the
university of north carolina at chapel
hill and we identified the University of
Wisconsin at Madison so I needed three
kids who have been who were rejected
from those three schools so I could have
three lawsuits I did this you know you
just can't start cold calling for kids
although I've tried that before so I am
I launched three websites a Harvard not
fair Oh RG UNC not fair Oh RG + UW not
fair Oh RG and because by this time you
know having had four cases of the
Supreme Court the launch of these
websites dig got some notoriety and the
lunch was covered by the times and the
New York Times and other newspapers and
over a two-week period I got probably
about 300 kids signed up on these
websites and lo and behold after flying
out to California a few times going to
North Carolina a few times but
unfortunately not going to Wisconsin I
found a group of kids who had been
denied admission to Harvard and a group
of kids who had been small group kids
who have been denied admission to UNC
and we filed a lawsuit challenging both
schools on November the 17th
the harvard law suit of course is the
one that has the highest profile because
our our plaintiffs at harvard are asian
and we argue that Harvard harbored has a
hard strict intractable quota on asians
today much like they had a hard strict
quota on jewish students in the 1920s
30s and 40s that lawsuit is underway our
first status conference with Harvard
will take place next month in Boston
Harvard as you can imagine has really
wired up they they just didn't go to you
know a really sharp litigation team
instead they went straight to President
Bill Clinton's former Solicitor General
Seth Waxman who has argued uh probably
about 50 cases before the US Supreme
Court and his his supreme court
litigation team so I think the the
speculation is that regardless of what
happens in the lower courts one of these
two cases and I'm hopeful to bring a
third anybody from Wisconsin knowing
that you know one of these cases will
eventually get to the Supreme Court and
Harvard specifically wanted to have
their Supreme Court advocates sort of
you know X square one if that is the
eventualities so I'm going to encourage
you to follow these lawsuits I make
periodic postings to our website project
on fair representation orgy you can
follow this I assume that if Fisher
Fisher to is taken up by the Supreme
Court in in early May then all of this
just becomes this
kind of bubbling booyah base of
affirmative action and it's my hope that
really between the Fisher case and some
of these new cases we will finally sort
of achieve what you know the great
founders and visionaries of the civil
rights movement taught us and that is
your race in your ethnicity really
shouldn't count for anything whether
it's in college admissions or jobs